Elden Ring has an optional tutorial now..so
hey, so go and turn off those annoying pop-ups
in the settings..watch this video, and be
free!
Free to go off..and die in a ditch somewhere.
1 - Charge Attacks
First, charge attacks.
In Elden Ring, they're incredibly powerful..and
who better to test them out on, than White-faced
Varre?
You maidenless runt..who do you think I am?
Charge attacks being powerful is one thing,
but what's really special, and important for
you to know..is just how MANY new TYPES of
attack can be charged.
Of course, weapon R2's can be charged for
more damage and posture damage..and even some
L2 weapon skills can be, like the Glintsword,
or the blood blade.
By holding R1, you can also now charge your
spells.
What's special about this, is that charged
variants of spells often have more than just
a damage multiplier.
Some, like dragonfire..can be channeled longer.
Others, like bubbles, persist longer before
popping..and when I used rejection, I noticed
its regular R1 didn't instantly dismount enemies..but
its charged attack did.
Experiment with charged magic..learn it fully:
because these charged spells cost the same
amount of FP as their regular variants.
Therefore, if you have the time or poise to
charge a spell, you probably should.
2 - Crafting
Another thing to get in the habit of is crafting,
which you can do as soon as you buy the crafting
kit from Kale.
After a few hours of play, you should have
accumulated a few recipe books to expand your
crafting options, and if you've been hunting
and foraging between bosses, then you'll be
able to make quite a bit here.
Pay attention to which material drops you
find in the world: It'll make it that tiny
bit easier to gather more of it when you realise
you need it to craft something specific.
The crafting page gives you hints at where
to find specific materials, and from what
I can tell, world materials respawn instantly
upon resting at a grace, making them fairly
easy to farm.
If there's one thing you want to farm in the
full game, it's sleep arrows.
These things are insanely powerful, offering
crazy crowd control mid combat, enhancing
your stealth, and opening enemies up for critical
attacks.
One interesting item here are cracked pots,
a container material you need to make thrown
consumables, like firebombs or sleep pots.
These cracked pots are magical, going back
into your inventory after you've thrown the
item you made with them.
That means if I buy 3 pots, then I can craft
3 firebombs.
Then, I can only craft 3 more firebombs if
I throw the 3 I've made.
Remember: they're a container, not a consumable..and
I reckon it's likely merchants later in the
game will sell you even more cracked pots,
and allow you to hold even more crafted bombs
at any one time.
3 - Spirit Summons
I didn't use any crafting items on my first
playthrough..and that was a mistake.
I spent over an hour on the first major boss
because I was stubborn, determined to beat
him with an underleveled, underpowered character,
with a weapon I didn't really like.
Don't make that same mistake.
Remember, this isn't Sekiro - if something
is giving you trouble, you don't JUST have
to git gud.
Instead, take a step back, and remember there
ARE creative ways around your problem.
First and foremost are spirit summons, powerful
companions that can be found around the world.
I get the impression that these will work
differently in the final game, but for now,
they are items that use FP, able to be equipped
to your quick-select bar in the equipment
menu.
They're able to be summoned in any area that
has this little obelisk..but that's not what
you should be looking for.
Instead, if you're in a difficult area, you'll
know it, because THIS icon will pop up on
the left, letting you know that you can summon
your spirits.
Some spirits, like the noble sorcerer, are
a sort of ranged DPS.
Others, like the wolves are melee fighters
with a lot of mobility.
If you're a faith build, you should also consider
healing them between battles with a heal spell
- hell, you can successfully heal them DURING
battle considering how quickly this spell
comes out.
So if you're really having trouble, decide
on the best spirit to suit the situation,
and try to overcome it that way.
4 - Stake of Marika
And if you fail..well, if a fight is difficult
enough to allow for spirit summons, then it
likely has a Stake of Marika as well.
If you're within its range, then you'll be
able to choose it as a respawn point upon
death.
Basically they're just here to prevent a long
run back from a site of grace.
They're easy to miss, but again,you shouldn't
always be looking out for the physical statue.
If you're within range of one, you'll get
a small status icon here, in the top left.
5 - Guard Counter
Try to make use of all of Elden Ring's mechanics
to stay alive.
One of the biggest additions to combat are
"Guard Counters".
Now, after you block an attack, whether with
a shield or a two-handed weapon, you can follow
up with a strong R2, accompanied by this sound
effect.
These attacks come out fast, they deal good
damage, and most importantly: enormous posture
damage.
Break an enemy's invisible posture meter,
and you'll be able to knock them down for
a critical strike.
So if you have a powerful shield, and are
confident that an enemy has just used the
last attack in their combo, then you have
so much to gain from using a guard counter.
Hell, even if you're two-handing a weapon,
Guard Counters give you a reason to block.
They're that good.
6 - Two-handing
So Elden Ring uses X or A as the jump button,
which means interact has moved to Triangle
and Y..which means the 2-handing input has
changed as well.
Now, to 2-hand a weapon or shield, you have
to HOLD triangle, then tap R1 or L1, depending
on which one you want to 2-hand.
It's a bit jarring at first, but actually,
this is a really nice input.
It's fast, and lets you quickly two-hand either
weapon, not just one of them.
Like in Dark Souls, 2-handing weapons increases
your damage output, and lets you get around
a lack of a strength stat, in many cases.
Additionally, Two-handing is even stronger
in Elden Ring because of the new posture system.
A 2-handed weapon will inflict greater posture
damage to your enemies, especially if you
use R2, charged R2's, or R2 jumping attacks.
7 - Ash of War
And that's not all, because 2-handing a weapon
gives you access to its assigned skill.
A weapon skill is something you activate with
L2, and the current one you will perform is
always written here, on the left side of the
screen.
Every weapon and shield comes with a default
skill, and while some of them are very unique
and locked to their weapon, like this one.........most
of them aren't, and can be changed, with "ashes
of war".
When you sit at a grace, select the Ash of
War option.
Here you can see all your basic weapons, but
also bows, catalysts, talismans and shields.
Remember to give them ashes of war as well.
Ashes of War come with a skill, but also a
couple of scaling options.
Be sure to pick the scaling that best suits
your stats.
Oh, and don't forget.
Kick is now an L2 skill, and can be performed
when your bare fists are out.
It functions similarly to Dark Souls, punishing
enemies severely if they have their shield
up.
8 - Powerstancing
Seeing a return in Elden Ring is powerstancing
- allowing you to draw additional benefit
from dual wielding, as long as both weapons
you have equipped are of the same type.
Here, for example, I have two greatswords.
Even though one is the crucible greatsword
and one is a bastard sword, both are greatswords,
so both can be powerstanced.
When I tap L1, I attack with both weapons,
dramatically increasing my damage and giving
me access to a powerful moveset.
This L1 can also be used in running attacks..but
perhaps most importantly, you can now also
do powerstanced L1 jumping attacks.
These are particularly useful while powerstancing
because they're a high-mobility attack, and
mobility is EVERYTHING when you don't have
a shield equipped.
This is also a great time to mention that
your jump also has iframes, allowing you to
dodge through enemy attacks AND queue up an
attack at the same time.
Of course, you don't need to powerstance to
do this - every weapon has access to R1 and
even heavy R2 jumping attacks, as well.
9 - Mount
One of the best ways to utilise jumping attacks
is off the back of your mount.
Dismount with L3, and slam them with L1, R1,
or R2.
The distance you cover with this is absurd,
and initiating a fight in this way gives you
an immediate advantage.
You can also dismount with the same whistle
item you use to mount, but I'd recommend getting
into the habit of using L3 instead, since
you'll commonly quick swap off the whistle
in order to heal.
Crimson flasks heal your character on horseback,
but they don't heal your mount, which CAN
take damage as well.
Torrent's health bar is pretty enormous, but
if a fight goes on long enough, it's possible
for him to die.
If this happens, you'll have to sacrifice
a crimson flask to revive him.
Instead, if you notice torrent taking a ton
of damage, heal him instead - rowa berries
found throughout the world can be used to
craft rowa raisins, which can be fed to Torrent
while mounted.
Before Torrent takes enough damage to die,
it's far more likely that you'll be knocked
off your horse instead.
This is done when your posture is broken,
and it puts you in a vulnerable state on the
ground for a really..really long time.
This is devastating, so it's probably a good
idea to fight on-foot after you've fought
on your mount for a little while.
While mounted, you can double jump to get
over more terrain, and sprint to move across
it quickly.
Interestingly, you don't have to HOLD circle
to sprint..you just have to tap it.
Tapping it gives you a burst of speed in exchange
for stamina, so remember to spam it when you're
desperately trying to outrun something, like
a dragon's flame.
Of course, while out of combat, sprinting
doesn't consume stamina at all.
While mounted, R1 and R2 give you light and
heavy attacks on the right side, and L1 and
L2 give light and heavy attacks on your left
side.
If you hold your heavy attacks, you can charge
them for a while in order to properly time
their release.
Interestingly, most weapons seem to have active
hitboxes WHILE you're charging the attack.
Some, like the lance seem to have a higher
hitbox, good for mounted enemies.
Others, like the greatsword, are dragged along
the ground, excellent for dispatching grounded
enemies.
The Twinblade on the other hand seemed to
have a very inconsistent hitbox while spinning,
so it's possible there are advantages and
disadvantages to each.
There are a variety of ways to take out enemies
on horseback.
You can target and kill their horse, then
fight the enemy alone....or you can target
them on horseback, and kill them to leave
their horse wandering.
Some enemies can be instantly knocked off
with sleep arrows..though horses seem to be
immune..or even with certain spells that deal
a ton of posture damage.
All of this is good, but the most stylish
way to take out a mounted enemy, is this:
A well-timed parry.
10 - Day & Night
This black horseman can only be fought at
night.
He patrols this bridge back and forth..and
it's in exactly the same manner as another
horseman does at day.
I even camped out here for a full day to try
and see if this daytime knight transforms
into the night..knight..and..he does, but
there's no transformation.
So this brings me to the day and night system.
In Elden Ring, a full day and night takes
exactly one hour to pass.
I know this, because I sat and timed the whole
thing.
The sun rises and sets in real time, rain
starts, rain stops..and all of it is a fantastic
addition to the game that really makes the
world feel alive.
But the true test of this system is its gameplay
implications..and so far, there are a few.
We mentioned the black knight, but bats also
spawn in more locations at night.
Overall, night seems like it contains more
difficult enemies..so if you prefer, you can
sit at a grace and pass time until morning.
This same time dial can be found any time
on your map screen, where it's even more specific
about the time of day..telling you whether
it's morning, afternoon, evening, and so-on.
I bet, and sincerely hope, that specific events
can only be found at these specific times
of day.
One benefit to night is that it seems to buff
your stealth.
The results of my test are on-screen: as you
can see here, this enemy spotted me here during
the day....and..here, at night.
I got far closer without being detected.
So if you're sneaking into a camp, perhaps
to grab a valuable item like the map fragment
in this camp..that's another excellent reason
to set your time of day at the Grace checkpoint.
..and if you get really close to enemies you
might be able to overhear..yup, I knew it.
He's listening to an audiobook with Audible!
Right now, for a limited time, save 46% on
your first 4 months of Audible.
That’s only $7.95 a month.
Give yourself the gift of listening.
For more go to audible dot com slash vaatividya
or text vaatividya to five hundred five hundred.”
The book I'm recommending this time is Dune,
a sci-fi classic that has recently been turned
into a feature film.
It's the best audiobook I've ever listened
to, featuring, at times, ambient music to
suit the mood, and even multiple voice actors
for its cast of characters.
Have a listen:
Hawat nodded, thinking: Perhaps I'm doing
it, getting across to him the importance of
this planet as an enemy.
It's madness to go in there without that caution
in our minds
Paul looked up at the skylight, aware that
it had begun to rain.
He saw the spreading wetness on the grey meta-glass.
"Water", he said.
"You'll learn a great concern for water.
As the Duke's son, you'll never want for it,
but you'll see the pressures of thirst all
around you."
I'm personally listening to Dune right now
so that I can go and enjoy the new movie afterwards.
I hope it lives up to the example the book
set, because I can see why people love this
so much now.
Anyway, whether you want to listen to this
or anything else from their huge selection
- go to audible dot com slash vaatividya or
text vaatividya to five hundred five hundred.”
..and thank you, as always, for watching.
I'll have another video on even more overlooked
mechanics soon, so subscribe and enable notifications
for that.
Before you go, I'd also like to say that Displate
has an insane Black Friday sale on right now,
where 1-2 displates are 33% off, 3-4 displates
are 37% off, and 5+ are 41% off.
I have more than 5 displates now, so if there's
any time to get your money's worth - this
is it.
A collection of the smaller plates can look
great.
But thank you for watching..and i'll see you
next time.